Hilary Clinton during an interview with
the LA Times question why quote anybody
with a beating heart and a working mind
still supports the president seriously
here with reaction Criminal Justice
advocate granted clemency by President
Donald Trump Alice Marie Johnson Fox
News contributor Ari Fleischer Alice
Murray I thought about you a lot
good to see you again spent two years
right since you've been free yes good to
see you John - and you said you Thank
You America Thank You Donald Trump and
and for giving me a second chance and
I'll never let you down I'll never
forget what you said
you're watching what's happening the
president from my political perspective
Alice criminal justice reform that
happened under his watch Opportunity
Zones helping historically black
colleges the lowest unemployment levels
ever for minority Americans now defund
the police I don't like that idea I'd
love to hear your thoughts I don't like
that idea either
I would like to know that if I'm having
trouble that I can call on the public
servants the police and that they're
going to protect me and my family so I
just don't think that that's a good idea
I've got family members who are police
officers and I know that they don't want
that label put on them the same way I
didn't want to label put on me as a bad
person I made a mistake and g18 what
least one time offense and you lost your
life first ever now I was I was marked
for death yeah and and what an amazing
calling you found in prison and
counseling younger prisoners and hadn't
changed in their lives around
all right Fleischer you know I've been
thinking a lot about this and I'm
thinking about it politically okay so
the democratic party is the party of
defunding the police why didn't they
make criminal justice before exactly and
first off Alice it's wonderful to see
you on this show and I'm so glad you're
free sorry
she doesn't have to admit of course you
of course you are I can understand why
good people
very good thank you if you if when you
care about people who are hurt and when
you care about people who were in need
II that's exactly why you need law and
order without law and order they're
never gonna get a chance in life they're
not gonna have what other people have
taken for granted which is safe
neighborhoods to grow up in where they
can be free to study where they can be
free to get a good education they don't
have to walk through metal detectors to
go to schools this is what law and order
brings in people's lives and as it's
those without or without who need it the
most
and that's what's so sad about this
whole movement and anyway it's just
derailed Sean it's just gone off the
rails when you talk about defund the
police eliminate the police Alice will
give you the last word if any if we love
our kids we gotta keep them safe and we
got to stop with these failing schools
it's gone on for decades we've got to be
able to look at the problem I'm so
thankful that the problem of criminal
justice reform has become a priority for
the white house looking at my case I
know that touch the heart of the
President and I know looking at what is
going on in the nation right now that's
part of criminal justice reform and I've
got confidence that that is it's going
to be a top priority rate it's great to
see you again I want every Perry Johnson
in prison set free god bless you